[Musique]
éloigné de tout et si proche à la fois
un site patrimonial un sentier inscrit
au Monument Historique un espace
fréquenté le département rend accessible
le sentier dilette à
Guillaume proprié lapartement de Man les
financeur des travx les agents de la
collectivité réceptionnent le chantier
mené par
l'onféement on est venu pour
réceptionner les
travxer de gu pour PIR
faire plusard est lare croisement
deer de Colorado de
sabernard fouche et les travx commen
réellement comm le 22 août 22 2016 et
terminé le 10 novembre 2016 3 mois de
travaux ont été nécessaires pour
réhabiliter un sentier construit en 1864
le plus difficile étant de sécuriser les
22 zones considérées à risque regarde le
plateau avec le vert clair là c'est des
campfriers là-bas et la BAR ensuite on
voit la route de la plain d' fouche dans
la falaise en
[Musique]
haut
c'est
[Musique]
long des travaux spéciaux pour sécuriser
la zone avant même de commencer à
réfléchir à son développement voilà
l'originalité de ce sentier la
préparation technique en terme de
sécurisation par rapport aux chutes de
Pierr ça c'est un aspect important un
autre aspect très spécifique à ce ce
chantier là c'est la découverte la prise
en compte et l'essai de protection et de
valorisation des murets là on est on
rentre dans un Vallet dans un volet
historique mais un volet aussi de gros
ouvrages d'art sur un sentier très rare
très rare à la Réunion cette réouverture
au public a été accompagné d'une
démarche scientifique géologue historien
botaniste et archéologues suivent de
près ce site qui raconte une partie de
notre histoire un enjeu de taille pour
le département qui souhaite donner un
sens à cette démarche c'est un projet
d'équipe donc qui a été financé à 75 %
par les fonds européens et 25 % par le
département il faut savoir que c'est un
investissement qui était à notre sens
important parce que ilett à Guillaume
est un site remarquable exceptionnel et
il faut absolument que les réunionnés le
découvrent ainsi que les touristes qui
viennent ses journer chez nous
[Musique]
le maronnage l'histoire du pénitentier
pour enfant voilà l'originalité de ce
site qui in trigotant une histoire
compliquée sur une époque difficile ù
bien des acteurs interviennent bien sûr
une grosse étude documentaire sur
l'ensemble de l'Ilette avec une
prospection pédestre sur l'ensemble de
la zone pour pouvoir repérer les
vestiges et euh les repérer
topographiquement ensuite faire une
véritable analyse du bâti pour pouvoir
documenter ces vestiges compléter avec
des sondages au sol pour pouvoir avoir
une stratigraphie complète sur euh sur
l'ensemble de l'îlette et et voir si on
a des occupations antérieures à cette
occupation 19e on sait que
potentiellement le site a été occupé dès
le 17e sièquele puisqueon parle de site
de maronnage donc c'est important de de
de vérifier par des sondages au sol
d'avoir une vraie lecture
stratigraphique euh peut-être une
réserve
[Musique]
d'eau avec une arrivée d'eau qui arriv
d'en
haut et peut-être mais ce ne sont que
des
hypothèses on peut potentiellement faire
des erreurs si on on connaît mal il faut
connaître où sont les vestiges à quoi
ils servaent quel éta le leur fonction
quel est leur état de conservation pour
bien déterminer les bonnes mesures à
prendre pour pour bien les protéger et
aussi bien les les valoriser on a vu sur
le sentier qu' en défrichant on dégageit
comme ça des murs de pierre sèche
magnifiqu ça sera peut-être aussi le cas
demain sur Guillaume on va dégager les
vestiges pour mieux les les contempler
aussi au fil des jours on pouvait sentir
une c excitation dans les discours que
va-t-on faire de ce site comment
concilier les différents usages dans cet
espace naturel voisin de
l'urbanisation une certitude l'ouverture
de ce sentier permettra maintenant à
toutes les forces en présence de donner
leur
[Musique]
avis